une question à présent dans ce journal
comment faire face à la péduie de
médecin l'une des solutions la
téléconsultation mobile et si vous
consultiez un médecin parisien depuis
chez vous en Loir et Cher c'est
maintenant possible pour se faire une
infirmière apporte un matériel
d'auscultation qu'elle utilisera selon
la demande du praticien une façon de
rendre accessibles les soins aux
personnes qui sont isolées et de
garantir un lien social Hélène
chapelet Sophia est la première
infirmière du Loir etcher équipée pour
réaliser des télé consultation médicale
au domicile des patients dans sa grosse
valise noire différents outils médicaux
connectés ce matinlà elle se rend chez
un patient à salalebri qui tousse et se
plain de douleur dans la gorge le Loiré
chérien n'a plus de médecin généraliste
et va tester pour la première fois la
téléconsultation les gens ont vraiment
un besoin ils sont bah désespérés parce
qu'ils ont pas de médecin leur solution
c'est SOS médecin mais c'est à romentin
donc il faut prendre la voiture c'est
compliqué
bonjour bonjour alors je vais vous
prendre une petite tension en attendant
le
médecin en attendant qu'un médecin se
connecte à la tablette l'infirmière
prend la tension le taux d'oxygène dans
le sang et la température du patient des
données qui pourront aider le praticien
à distance à poser son
diagnostic je me sens pas je me sens
fatigué pas bien et un peu de tout et un
peu mal à la
gorge après 15 minutes d'échang et de
vérification rien de grave sans doute un
peu de fatigue après de vaccins réalisés
il y a quelques jours alain est
rassuré mais c'est une très bonne
solution je pense en plus il y a un
matériel très performant ils ont leur
matériel très performant avec eux là
donc c'est haut de gamme bonne bon
retour merci au revoir on a tous connu
le médecin qui venait chez nous et
maintenant bah c'est fini ça n'arrivera
plus il faut prendre conscience que il
faut trouver d'autres solutions d'autres
moyens regarder vers 2030 céder de la
technolog de l'intelligence artificielle
de tout ce qu'on a aujourd'hui en 2023
et
évoluer cette expérimentation lancée
début octobre dans le sud du département
doit également s'implanter dans le nord
du loirécher à moisi à terme six
infirmières doivent être recruté pour
fonctionner 7 jours sur 7 le Conseil
départemental s'est engagé à financer
leur salaire 280000 €
d'investissement de notre plan le 41 en
bonne santé où on a différents axes
stratégiques pour essayer aussi de faire
venir des des professionnels de santé
des internes en stage et ça c'est un des
outils qui nous permet de répondre à à
l'accès aux soins qui est compliqué dans
notre département mais également dans la
région Centre valdeloire et dans
beaucoup de départements français selon
la RS en août 2023 le Loiré cher
comptabilisait 245 médecins généralistes
pédiatres ou gynécologu en activité il
en faudrait quasiment 70 de plus pour
atteindre la moyenne
nationale